ascenseur émotionnel pour 4000
supporters français au Qatar encore sous
l'effet d'un match renversant
ce quart de finale la ministre des
Sports Amélie ou des accastéral la suivi
depuis les tribunes au Qatar et sa tenue
était haute en symbole en un pull bleu
évidemment mais avec un détail des
manches arc-en-ciel je ne comprends pas
et je n'admets pas les tentatives de
récupération par quelques groupes que ce
soit par quelqu'un
mon soutien en faveur des droits humains
des droits LGBT
j'ai beaucoup apprécié l'initiative de
la ministre des Sports qui est
l'occasion d'ailleurs de s'en expliquer
ce matin et qui a également expliqué
qu'elle s'en était entretenues avec les
autorités locales qui n'avaient pas vu
de problème donc il y a pas de malice
une qualification historique en
demi-finale d'une Coupe du Monde une
victoire qui plonge des millions de
marocains dont l'allégresse les Bleus
vont affronter le Maroc ce sera une fête
en tout cas ce que je cède pour avoir
parlé avec des policiers c'est que c'est
une grande frayeur pour la police je
sais qu'ils sont parfaitement à la tâche
ils savent que ce sont des événements
qui peuvent poser des conditions un peu
un peu risqué mais encore une fois les
choses se déroulent pour l'instant très
bien depuis le début de la compétition
quelques débordements notamment sur la
plus belle avenue de France sur les
Champs-Élysées et quelques vingt mille
personnes y étaient rassemblées hier
après la victoire du Maroc puis de la
France 74 ont été interpellés
essentiellement pour des tirs de
mortiers il y a aujourd'hui des
supporters qui non content de célébrer
la victoire de leur pays d'origine se
doivent de taper de détruire de saccager
tout ce qui bouge et de s'acharner aussi
sur sur les policiers je dis que quand
on est français on est pour la France et
si on est franco-marocain on n'a pas le
droit d'être pour le Maroc contre la
France non c'est une preuve
supplémentaires que la francophobie est
un sentiment de plus en plus répandu en
France il y a une probabilité c'est pas
c'est probable je tiens les mots où tu
es une importance parce que vous savez
je reçois comme vous sur les réseaux
sociaux des messages de gens qui disent
mais alors on va on va manquer de
courant on va passer l'hiver dans le
noir enfin on n'a jamais eu l'intention
de faire peur aux Français les Français
sont pas des chaussettes ils sont hyper
responsables au contraire ils ont tous
bien entendu que chacun devait faire un
effort que l'effort devait porter être
porté partout que la situation était
compliquée c'est une preuve de plus de
la tiers mondialisation de ce pays et
une preuve de plus que quand vous savez
quand je disais qu'il fallait depuis des
années et je l'ai beaucoup dit pendant
la campagne un plan pour le nucléaire il
y a beaucoup de gens qui me rabrouaient
et ben maintenant il ne comprennent pas
pourquoi il y a des coupures
d'électricité entre les propos d'estrade
et certains qui font leur beurre si vous
me permettez l'expression sur le dos des
boulangers ça n'est pas parce que le kWh
pas encore fait x 4 que ta facture fait
fois 4 donc il est très important déjà
que les fournisseurs avec le
gouvernement expliquent sur la facture
d'énergie à quelle sauce la facture va
être et donc on leur a dit avec Bruno Le
Maire qu'il fallait plus de clarté 65 +
49-3 ça fait combien 65000
à votre avis 65 c'est quoi 65 c'est
peut-être le futurage de départ à la
retraite et 49.3
c'est ce que j'entends dans votre
question il n'y a match aujourd'hui chez
les républicains les 91.000 adhérents
votent électroniquement pour désigner
leur futur patron un second tour
d'élection qui oppose le député des
Alpes-Maritimes ericsiotiques partisans
d'une droite dure avec une ligne assez
radicale sur l'immigration et la
sécurité et le patron des sénateurs LR
le Vendéen Bruno retaillot fin du
suspense Éric ciottier donc élu avec
53,7% des voix et vous avez raison de le
dire c'est un score plus serré que prévu
les Anglais rentrent à la maison
d'ailleurs petite idée cadeau de Noël
pour les consoler une nouvelle télé